we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here are some really basic questions
about q anon that i myself have been
asking
hey david i have a question regarding q
anon
i still don't fully understand i mean
from what we know it means
one person account or multiple people
from one account
how is it that this person hasn't been
exposed yet he says he's a government
insider yeah you believe that the fbi is
actually investigating who this person
is
how this say started you know
and where the responsibility lies as far
as
holding this person accountable for i
have no
idea these are the questions i've been i
i
i get the idea that some people think q
might be trump some people believe q is
a group of people
others believe q is an individual how
does q communicate i guess originally it
was via 4chan but
more recently it's something else it's
as incoherent to me as it is to you
and to many of the people in our
audience and i don't know if we'll ever
get the answers to the questions that
are being asked but they are good
questions
we have a great bonus show for you today
anti-vaxxers briefly were able to shut
down dodger stadium's vaccination site
over the weekend
it's actually insane what's going on
with the anti-vaxx movement in the
united states
the number of hate groups declined in
2020
but the number of hate incidents went up
that's an interesting
series of facts that we're going to
discuss and we will also talk about
this situation between vice president
kamala harris
and democratic senator joe manchin who
is the most conservative democratic
senator in the u.s senate
what's going on with the two of them we
will discuss that and
much much more on today's bonus show
get instant access instant truly the
speed of light access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code better21 to
get yourself
a massive discount off of the cost of
the membership of your choice i'll see
you then
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn
from your checking account but your real
card number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman